bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
défilé spécial extinction au le saigne
on ne vous apprendrons tous les petits
secrets des stars pour briller dans son
biotope sont jamais ces temps de
réchauffement et la d'occasion des
bonnes résolutions de soigner ça dit il
n'y a pas de se donner les meilleures
chances de succès reproductif bien sûr
est de vous donner quelques petites
astuces pour filer entre les mailles de
la crise biologique
s'il ya bien une espèce qui ne connaît
pas la crise ce d'homo sapiens toujours
plus inventifs quand il s'agit de faire
croître sa population il est à la pointe
de la madelon le tiennent pour
responsable ou non de la crise ne change
rien au fait que c'est lui qui donnera
la tendance pour les années à venir
voici donc quatre trucs faciles pratique
et pas cher pour accroître votre fille
faith et rester à la pointe de la mode
sans jamais vous défilez astuce faites
attention à votre ligne
homo sapiens n'a ni de bon dieu n'y a
pas nos draps sachez donc vous faire
discret le mieux pour échapper aux homo
sapiens c'est encore de se faire oublier
tous ces messieurs qui arborent des
attributs tapageur et toutes ces d'avro
forme un peu trop ronde
il attire beaucoup trop l'attention
c'est le meilleur moyen de finir en
trophée ou en affreux 10e les éléphants
le savent bien à en avoir de trop
longues
on finit rapidement par se retrouver
sans défense faites comme eux adopté la
nouvelle tendance la tendance à la
baisse
adapter la sobriété il vaut mieux être
moins grands moins impressionnant et moi
sexy plutôt que d'être définitivement
has been
les iem astruc ce rendez vous utile les
êtres vivants qui compte pour loeb sont
ce qu'ils sont utiles là ne résiste pas
à ce qui améliore son petit confort
elle va mener vis et pantoufles emmener
en balade ou bien fait partie des
espèces qu'ils ramènent le petit
déjeuner au lit
une fois qu'il ne pourra plus se passer
de vous que ça valait pour les succès ce
gars ici les animaux et les plantes
domestiques en bien compris ça me
réussit bien
avec plus de 500 millions de
représentants dans le monde
les chiens sont hyper pas chaîne là où
l'argent le lot sauvage ville ou qui
sont mille fois moins nombreux sont loin
d'avoir la hype et avec un effectif
chiffré à plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'individus la poule
domestique est certainement l'animal qui
a le plus la cote
astuce faites vous des idées quand il
obtient tout de suite l'homme de ce
fonds en profiter sachez jouer de vos
charmes fait lui miroiter quelle belle
plante vous êtes et peut-être sera-t-il
en jouir plus longtemps ce qui me
laissera le temps à vous d'en profiter
pour vous reproduire bien sûr si vous ne
parvenez pas à vous rendre utile sans
vous faire plumer
faites donc comme les chats jouer de vos
atouts félins pour vous faire entretenir
aux frais du big band un bon capital qui
tenait ce sensibilisera votre public
comme unité et peut vous propulser dans
le haut du panier en osier top ten et
qui sait cela pourrait vous sauver de la
disparition quatrième astuces
sachez accommoder les restes homo
sapiens qu'à ce prix c'est là son
moindre défaut toutes ces ordures c'est
un peu plus en mai un petit sans
fouiller dans les poubelles
ce n'est pas très glamour mais qu'on
soit en [ __ ] laveur un ours à goélands
un renard un beau brun quand on a pas
on se refuse rien mais attention à ne
pas manger n'importe quoi non plus la
junk food c'est bien mais un peu dur à
digérer pour conclure la nature n'a ni
moral ni pitié c'est l'enfer de la mode
survivre dans le vaste monde n'a jamais
été une partie de plaisir
même avant que ne s'ouvre le petit
défilé des hominidés toutes les espèces
sont capables du pire et ne vivent que
pour payer les alors si on ne veut pas
en plus concourir contre mots sa pièce
le mieux c'est encore d'apprendre à
vivre avec peu voire même l'apprivoiser
contrairement à ce que ce gros
prétentieux de recettes vient se croit
sa présence n'est pas toujours synonyme
de mort pour tous qui fit il offre comme
tous les animaux des opportunités de
survie et il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
s'en prive
il faut simplement apprendre à tirer le
meilleur parti de ce qu'ils produisent
pire mais si toutefois vous êtes trop
fier pour arrêter la lutte vous pouvez
toujours faire comme les insectes les
bactéries ou les bélougas et évoluer
plus vite que lui
ou en tout cas plus vite que sa capacité
à tourner et année merci à tous au fait
c'était quoi le but la diro êtres
vivants de se débrouiller pour s'adapter
à toutes les choses débiles qu'on fait
non parce que ça m'étonnerait qu'il nous
écoute tu sais non mais non c'était pour
illustrer différentes stratégies
adaptatives qu'adopte certains êtres
vivants en réponse à l'affluence que
l'être humain assure leur environnement
tout n'est pas néfaste chez l'homme
adacore le message donc c'est que
l'homme fait aussi partie de
l'environnement
non en fait c'est que l'homme est un
environnement
et pas seulement pour ces bactéries
intestinales